citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to conclude the dcamu because today we are
watching Apocalypse war and guess what we haven't
seen it nope because that's how this works please
do leave a like please do subscribe for
not already and please do leave a comment
recommending the thing we watch next because
once this ends frankly all bets are off we're
gonna stick with DC for a while there's a lot
of good DC we haven't watched but the universe
ends today and that is very exciting speaking
of universes ending flash may have concluded
that universe but you know it hasn't ended Batman
and you should check out the bat verse shirt yes
these lovelies have over at shopzeroeddition.com
and if you want to also support these lovelies
please come to San Diego Comic-Con on Saturday
we've got a panel the big day they give us a big
day panel San Diego Comic-Con real rejects
paneling it up we are very excited so hope
to see you there I think without further Ado if
you want to be a patron you can watch this front
to back start to finish with our resting faces
otherwise it's time to get into it let us War
all right who's gonna be driving today [Music]
a little tiny little uh Mini Cooper the apocalypse
job yes a pocket car apocacon I like the idea of
a buckles and Mini Cooper though that's strong
it's gray like a gunmetal [Music] here's hoping
that I love you didn't think that was
in dousy the legal sold this out and
we'll be having pints by Sundown
absolutely true I hope that we
get to end this on a Constantine
movie yeah that's great excited
will Hawkman speak as it was now or never
this is apocalypse Homeworld of Darkseid
Raven what's wrong it's nothing no it's not it's
never nothing Raven what's your daddy saying up
there these are images from Worlds that Darkseid
has conquered oh we have to attack there's always
a deal to be made let's at least send an Envoy
to apocalypse no yeah nah Darkseid created a
monster that nearly killed me what chance would
Humanity have our only option is to destroy him
that means Earth could be Ground Zero in World
War world's War yeah the main team will attack
through this entryway in Apocalypse members of
the Titans shall remain on Earth as a Home Guard
and only Power demons to guard him
Darkseid will be vulnerable to attack oh he's
invited to the meeting he's just checking out
honey please get somewhere safe I may not be
able to fight this war but I can report the story
worrying super Apple watch I was gonna
say who made this watch I want one
use his own home screen for a second love that
guy ah look at how great I am I Am the Man of
Steel aren't uh man of tomorrow canonically I
think that speech should have came from Batman
but you know I feel like Superman saying
to strike first isn't exactly it but anyway
one I get that he was almost killed I get his
Vengeance but I still feel like between the two
koi if there's even a one percentage when Lex
Luthor's like maybe let's not be antagonists I
love that he's still part of the league too it's
just hanging out it's just testing how far he can
get in one of these meetings they're too big to
be parademons then what the hell are those things
flying monkeys Sarah devils wow
yep intense
we're gonna be blending Titans league and darkness
it's exciting Boogie oh this has clearly gone well
oh beautiful spoilers I guess it didn't work
out desolate but beautiful the glands are
full of whiskey I mean lots of whiskey
VHS are gonna be a breeze after the G's
[Music]
we need him John it's me
Clark Kent you knew me as Superman
what's up with your eyes oh it is you
now you've done it
stop it
I mean a chair chair probably not gonna
do this throw the bar at him I can't
oh he's got like Kryptonite in him whoa
that's messed up little help would be nice
yes yes
now spit a bar at the bar bloody nuisance
well there's no sense come on man you have
one job aside from killing you
know demons also being a demon
and I'm sober again magic can be such a
[__] I love this all super and magical
Heroes have problems staying drunk yeah
it burns right through gift from dark side
liquid Kryptonite they keep me from ever being a
threat cruel booger off Clocky I told you he was a
waste of time all cowards are oh now you've done
it I didn't lead us all into a massacre you did
Zatanna was a hero who fought bravely no but
where were you when she needed you most no I
love them together yeah Zatanna would want
you to hear us out below the belt Boy Scout
come with if you want what about you etragon
who refilled your beer etch again whatever
the whatever League what does it rhyme with come
on so much rhymes with whatever shoe leather why
I never been all mopey ever since a friend
of his died doesn't even rhyme anymore oh
no Darkseid knew every part of our plan those
things that attacked us were half parademon
half doomsday no paradoomsday Darian Hal fought
hard but we're taken down no love them Shazam
Jeremy Johns Shazam was wounded I think Black
Adam was the other one oh no that was him
oh foreign they always jack up cyborg
in the most horrible ways that's brutal
tell me Batman made it somehow there's
somehow some he had plans for yep
I will test my tattoo gun out on you
[Applause] oh that's so messed up
no
no I don't know why I ran been up against
all sorts of bastards and I always stood tall
because you didn't have your
five o'clock shadow we just
need a locator spell I need some gear so
sit tight etragon continue loafing done
I do like Mo Pietro again hope
he Rhymes at the very end when
things go well yes yes yes Solace the
finale will get a rhyme with apocalypse
foreign
City I like that gotta see it still with
that ordinance the Guardians of owa will
be forced to Bow before me the Damage Done To
The Apocalypse reactor during the attack two
years ago your attack my solution is working
oh the power generated is less than your
previous reactor it sounds like the Batman
a major ship looks like the Batman molding
didn't fully transform you into a capable servant
perhaps you'd serve me better as a Mindless drone
oh wow I am still your most competent acolyte
Lord Darkseid your former teammate Luthor
believes otherwise yes he does who am I finding
Damien Wayne oh I have to conjure a portal from
scratch big enough for all of us oh and
everyone has to stay still while I'm sick
no you're too weak why are
we careful everything will
go according to darkseid's schedule do you
know if I'm included in his lordship's plans
don't worry about your place in those plans worry
about doing what I tell you oh of course Batman
he's such a sniveler now Lex Luthor
curious what level of long game Batman
must be playing to like yeah right
It's gotta be gotta be a betrayer
assassins hey come on buddy you
love yourself some challenge
oh
no it'd be so hard to like have to
learn how to defend yourself when
all your life it's been like incredibly
easy don't feel a thing die demon [Music]
oh yeah Talia oh no Damian oh
they're his people I know you hate me
but I wouldn't be here if it wasn't necessary
I'll let you live for now if you bring me a
fresh turtleneck I've been out for years and
frankly that's all I know my neck is cold
outside
you're not getting out father
Release Me or I will kill the boy
no you harm one hair on Damien's head
steal anything and I'll cut your hands off
oh I really like that you two should
team up Damien and natural Damian
demon there's some Rhymes in there
big work Batman believed in you you
cost me my father and my teammates oh whoa yeah oh
damn oh Nightwing oh oh I was afraid
that was almost about oh that was bad
about having you just got here look you
even got a line in this movie nope damn
there are always risks in war he
said he's not saying that anymore
oh oh
no help us fix things he overcame my
mother's brainwashing once if anyone
could survive darkseid's programming hippy father
oh yeah but the only way to apocalypse
is to use the boom tube in Lex Corp Tower
how do you expect to do that let me make some
calls finally beat the crap out of Lexus I'm
thinking about this for years she's a people
person so I'm sure the Situation's well in hand
wow
Lois and Harley yes what Lois she looks
like she can handle herself come on Ollie
Havana cold one what a couple of fun
Sheila's beat each other bloody Amos
of course Boomerang got lines here
and of course he's like completely
Untouched by all of this everything's fine
Aussies Palms convicts do your best time
the most Superman line yet
that was so good I love that
at Constantine and Boomerang together
perfect moments you gotta be kidding
he always gotta be kidding this scene's
full of bars this is a good scene yeah
[Applause] nicely done The Sting ladies and gents
of The Suicide Squad because tomorrow we take back
this planet we died in Hell Lois got everyone
decided her via fist fight with Harley Quinn
I love that magic that's so good oh bullets
is my ex you and Harley do I look mad yes yes
that's right queer icon John Constantine great
how did Amanda Waller let a lunatic like
you become leader of the squad she died
the card didn't work that's perfect setup from
that oh that's so good we'll be taking our cut
from Luthor Supply train since this [__] show
started nice real Robin Hood types Rob from the
rich and sell to the poor give to the poor huh
they're doing a good job tying up a lot of loose
ends so how'd you end up with Kent you left
and I was alone I just wanted to end the pain
God how do you get back I mean dark stuff
might have been put in there is like a lesson
see Superman walking around broken that's like
yeah I'm around the whole planet's down and then
the place that should give him power Korea's
not yeah I had feelings for you if you didn't
you made the right decision I left because my
father wants to kill you I couldn't risk that
the heck are they they phased the Earth magma
to darkseid's base and they're playing it up
we plan on mounting simultaneous attacks on
two of the machines why not attack all three
we don't have enough people yeah I was thinking
that dark side is going to owa once we're there
we shut down the portal so he can't come back how
do you know he'll be gone did you steal his diary
yes you have a source in darkseid's Camp called
sleeper he or she has been slipping me information
for months or they Batman I know this plan has
astronomical risks and impossible odds you're
the suicide squad blah blah blah let's do this
thing yes sir so it's actually justice league dark
suicide Titans apocalypse War he has the original
working title it's uh it's a bit of a journey
who are these guys wowie king shark is a shark my
friend here was to attack my thugs
we killed him right back yep yeah
just siree Bob you betcha gotta get my
friend to a duck how are you can we go
I mean it worked glorious not a bad American
accent Boomer I go to claim owa for my Empire
do not interrupt me this is my private time
my private murder time of lanterns now that
my arms are crossed I will not uncross
them he does the all right it's hard to
cross back there yeah it's good stretch
though it is feels nice yeah everyone
at home stretch I'm sending the signal to
attack the machines China team is engaged
box office numbers
it's got like a gold leg of energy yeah I wonder
where she went after she kicked me out the house
hey
guys we never did get our house movie
yeah oh Batman Beyond is beyonding
whoa or is it batwing oh it's like yeah that guy
that's right yeah Batman Beyond it this universe
will be sick though yeah I forgot we got that
whole team introduction in Universe yeah 30
person cast I'm not getting a signal that any
of the paradums have left apocalypse another
debacle Damien geez we should have gathered a
third Force this is my fault it's a debocolypse
oh
I thought I'd pop by to
discuss fertilizer and the such
yes yes my dude one day one
day they're leaving already
but just know that this thing here will
be the death of your precious screen
I'm listening here's your third team in one
love it the green green well not die yes
yes oh damn dude Swamp Thing super effective
astral projection solve the whole thing yep
what did you say that day why did you say that
game that game how did you play that game that
was good that's how we finish the the dciw
combination that's where we got to that's
we're gonna be proud yeah that's how they Omega
for etragonal rap over the credits yes Will Smith
style he has to say every team that's in the movie
yeah and rhyme it and every character individually
yes everyone in the universe fighting yes
what a culmination
[Music] [Laughter]
amazing oh glad it's all rated for her
best boss ever you sure sign me up [Music]
dang shot in the face I think shiva's had like a
couple small appearances through this yeah she's
had her little little cameos yeah but someone
had to get a shot in the face to show the stakes
oh
it's not going around my camera Furious I
hope you actually are Luther what the hell
what is this this way keep it moving gang
you said this would be hard it's not hard
a repeat word technically Rhymes all right all
right he's getting there he's warming up yeah
I'm afraid you don't have
the proper clearance okay
ouch
[Music]
nice
what a great line cold no one will mourn you
I was surrounded and the battle was over I had
to make a choice I've been helping Lois ever
since uh I was wondering if that was the bait
and switch because it's not Batman yeah yeah
who changed sides when it suited him that's
also what makes you think she won't do it
again he wants to be a hero deep down and
he does want to save the planet that's kind
of his thing yeah I was hoping Alex would
have some kind of face-ish and then it's that
life equation actually corrupting Batman yeah
[Music]
as a team to himself
oh oh so Much Death
whoa dude
I was gonna say I wonder where his personality is
like now messy do you want me to add your soul to
my ledger my body has to be more than dead huh
the last accursed Dagger of a Stover keep daddy
in his pen and we won't have to go down that
road I can do it you got this I believe in you
oh fires Kryptonite infused missiles and high
explosive rounds perfect for paradums hey but
you made it to kill my husband if I had issues
don't look a gift horse in the mouth you know
so many Kryptonite weapons make sense Lois you
someone has to make sure the portal stays closed
come back to me Smallville [Music] ah Smallville
she just wanted the show renewed yeah I'm willing
you know and Rosenbaum the best Lutheran
absolutely Luthor there's been unauthorized
use of the portal from lexcorp just to
power surge Batman it's nothing already
handled all hail Dark Side you finally
decided to reveal your traitorous nature
Lord Darkseid will kill you slowly excellent
well I guess I'm completely on your side now
oh that's so good only at that moment yeah
I'm completely on your team oh that's good
I like how chilly is just floating
around there she's doing it
wow
oh kilowog teleport a portion of Earth's
magma here I'd like to make a point jeez ugh
[Music]
that's dark
God damn it oh
[Music] oh cyborg mirror damn
whoa oh Martian Manhunter
all their friends oh
damn so icky the furies are rough oh man Diana
I'm sorry this happened to you yes seriously
Corey it's me you're being controlled
they salvaged like the two halves yeah
[Music]
Hawkman looks like a nightmare these
Furies are terrifying yeah oh easy princess
there he is
yes my dude go off Wonder
Woman cyborg versus etrahan
[Music]
nice that's a good shot
ow oh
yeah do you bleed cause I do
[Music]
Oh I thought he had her no this is gonna make
him more excited and love will get a giggle out
of him might not get that that rhyme scheme
my race is run I regret nothing huh it was
fun [Music] last second got it in there he died
as he lived spitting bars we've got final bar
oh fun you were a paragon for
warriors Through the Ages not
dark sides minion Break Free now whoa cool nice
pair of Constantine compels you that
was cool Diana at the mascara yes yes
there's a tunnel behind you leading to the
power generator leave them to me [Music]
I mean I guess it's hard to wake people up
when they're all attacking you at once yeah
for Clark and the team to have any chance
those monsters can't get back to apocalypse
last call then Kryptonite whiskey buckle
up suicide squatties today's the day we
earn our name Lois and likes of
The Suicide Squad it's beautiful
what oh poor Barry no it's just
been running this whole time no
oh that's awful and that's just Barry
he doesn't look all like fried out oh
I mean he does but you know not like not
corrupted I'm possessed just trapped yeah
[Music]
whoa it was phased on a mega Bean hit
a apocalypse reactor damage converted
me to replacement make it stop you
gotta make me stop oh God sleep late
ah oh he caused it if he doesn't go back to
save his mum dark side is in here we go through
what are you planning Constantine
it's magic you wouldn't understand
[Music]
oh I just ripped that guy's
spine out whoa Mortal Kombat
glad they all get their moments
nice oh
I'll kill you boy not great
none can resist dark side
[Music]
what is happening
It's Gonna Hurt
oh I didn't expect that he's connected to
them all that's fantastic we got some folks
back now they're like those toys in Toy Story
that look evil but aren't yes Batman stepped
out to talk to the big Batman's return
and with his Lord and Master you well
ouch I thought that was gonna go but
she won't pick us apart so easily father
you dare call me that what did you say that name
your mother drugged me to conceive you goaded me
into raising you and broke me mentally I see you
were never my son nah only a burden come
then and your burden once and for all yes
Batman with no conscience
I would not want to fight
[Applause]
come on
Jesus
Bruce don't ah
Crime Alley
finish you oh go to hell yes
leaving the bat slave yes you
disappoint me ugh no oh oh damn
[Music]
do it whoa
I'm offering you a willing magical
host wow I have a better idea
no no
whoa whoa
what
what ah I did not see that Counting
so many are dead come on push
double eyes that's how you do it yes
oh an emperor father Justice not vengeance
sad Batman guess me man oh Lois Bruce 40 seconds
send the message to Clark's mech suit now so
we can see it good to have you back bets yeah
I know we planned on always being together
but that's not going to happen now Lois
oh what is this
oh damn Captain Boomerang is a boomerang
snuggle it's been an honor to fight by
your side geez are you [__] me
hahaha [Laughter] amazing we all
understand king shark now now we're part of
the family we're part of the suicide squad
wow
yes
whoa is let's go he's back and he got shaved
real quick little Kryptonite shape yeah
is Damian's sword
yes
[Music]
nah wait on him [Music] yes ah yeah
we'll need Constantine well that's a problem oh
hello John but how in the hell did you get me
into heaven I needed to apologize for making you
run away when I died huh oh wow a compulsion spell
let's see he thought we should have a backup
plan in case everything went wrong [Laughter]
[Music]
okay our friends still need your
help I'm dead you of all people
should know that means nothing
when Destiny's involved [Music]
I love you oh
yes
tears
[Music]
wow cool
holy [__] he's alive
oh oh
dang Vic do we have a way out working on it
come on
oh guys don't make this overly
emotional father it wasn't your fault
you've already deployed the bat hug we're
good Pat bonding accomplished yes we're
not leaving Clark behind Darkseid needs to
be distracted for me to do my thing yeesh
you can't be serious uh-huh
you have Spirit Kryptonian with the strength
of a lost love is what were you saying
let's go unless you would fight me for the right
to destroy him nah we good I got my licks oh
yep yep yep
what a wonderful gift daughter well
at peace goodbye father
looks like I get the last word
yes suck it [__] yes [Music]
yes off into Oblivion
look at that
[Music]
t for Triumph what up giant movie yeah right
that was a lot a thick boy that was a lot of
moving Parts like eight C's on that man
we lost 31 of the Earth's molten core
the planet's rotation is compromised the smallest
change either way will mean freezing or burning
wow you know what you have to do mate start
again another flash point oh it won't be perfect
it'll be a long side better
than what we got now yeah truly
oh
go Barry [Music]
yes
damn
oh at last oh
into Oblivion
I love that it ended to the Trinity yeah
wow dude that was intense that was that was a
crazy one man yeah that was big and and thick
and so many things they did and had to do in
accomplishing successfully and wow yeah that's
the crazy part about so many of these movies and
especially the more aventi ones the more sort
of like every player is on the board like yeah
it's like we got an hour 25 minutes to to make
this feel like a two and a half hour movie and
somehow they're really good at doing that I can't
believe that was a Batman movie and a Suicide
Squad movie and a dressless league movie and a
justice league dark movie and Teen Titans movie
and an Apocalypse movie and like that was crazy
yeah like we we knew them well because but I don't
know how John certain Swamp Thing got cast first
but good for them sure uh knowing everyone already
obviously gave us a lot of Shemar Moore was hybrid
that's cool yeah um knowing everyone already was
obviously a huge asset but they did so much Tony
Todd as dark side Rebecca Romaine is Lois Lane
thought I recognized the voice uh but man they
did so much more than I thought possible in one 90
minute movie I know right that was insane yeah and
like again not overcrowded like every it really
people got moments yeah and it's very rewarding
after all of the movies that have led up to it
too don't think it would have been without them
no totally really had to go the way we went yeah
I would be very fascinated like I bet this would
still be quite thrilling to peer in on if you
just watched only this but yeah it's like not
being invested in Suicide Squad they'd just
be like one note joke whereas like here I was
like oh they're Landing their like long arcs
yeah and and yeah not only with them but with
various other characters as well and yeah you
get payoffs for the Teen Titans you get things
wrapped around for Constantine for Superman
and Lois for the Batman and Dame in storyline
like so many things long uh you know payoffs
of like the cancer thing with Amanda Waller
that are truly set up in other films that like
have to go here yeah and like the lesson of
Damien being taught to Bruce there are things
I would tweak though like I I would have loved
a moment where Bruce had like you know was in the
middle of enacting Vengeance at dark side and he
had to listen to Damien's advice sure I would have
loved to see it's still I mean it would have been
a simple writing tweak to have it be Superman uh
enacts something that is too um soft like Batman
got two different speech yeah so Batman gets the
opening speech he's like we have to strike first
we strike now and then he's unsuccessful because
Superman says we can't be murderers and that's
why everybody won't blame Superman and that's
how Batman gets corrupted that makes way more
sense than like why was the opening like Vengeance
Superman I get that he was almost killed I get all
those things that's not Superman I get the yeah
and I do agree it's all you change and it fixes
everything it doesn't it's not uh uh like to me
it was the kind of thing where I was like I can
see a version of Superman who just like reads the
writing on the wall and was like yeah this isn't
gonna go well and we have to get ahead of the game
but it still doesn't feel a hundred percent like
something Superman would do or say and I can see
him supporting it but not enacting it I can see
it being like you know what Batman's right we have
another Choice and then in the moment going like
we can't do this like that to me would have made
both allotments work yeah you're like a knocking
did you heard that too right yeah it
sounded like it was outside that wall weird
hello there's a ghost in the room it's a very
it was very loud like I don't know I've recorded
hundreds of hours here as a view that was crazy
what happened there but yeah I just feel like
that was something that bothered me but like that
that I'd change just certain characterizations
of this universe never quite rang true to me
but man that's my only negative like it was so
much positive yeah that did feel kind of like ah
you know not that I know the 100 like oh they're
trimming the trees ah this is it's literally right
outside there's a lot of real life going there's
a lot and it's very distracting apology I had to
acknowledge it yeah it felt like kind of a beat
that that might have been like truncated from an
earlier draft Yeah because I do agree with that
it seems like much more of a Batman philosophy to
be like we should strike like any time striking
first and a tactical plan yeah yeah 100 the plan
a plan and yeah and like a fully thought out like
I am you like there's three of us do this yeah
totally totally and then maybe because of the
Betrayal of Superman not enacting it uh his rage
allows dark decides life equation to get in its
head and then he's corrupted like yeah there
are things that would have served all of it
better yeah that's absolutely but I really liked
how they had the time Jump so we got to be like
whoa the world's messed up and then you you slow
burn discover what happened to everyone I really
enjoyed the like okay we've discovered having
this team oh there's another team oh we've got
a it like really narratively paced well yeah
because that was a crazy name and it drew just
the circumstances and who would be corrupted
who would perish and who would be left you know
as the sort of dregs trying to figure out one
last-ditch attempt at saving everything like I
thought the displacement of everybody was really
nice and yeah the way that they gradually you know
worked up to the the ultimate plan of how do we
stop this and and yeah having that one-two punch
of like dark sides coming and he's gonna you know
reshape the Earth and steal our research you know
we gotta act now and then immediately cut to and
we failed miserably and uh and now we gotta undo
this and yeah to have all that effort go toward
vanquishing dark side but then realizing that
it's too late really yeah and there's just gonna
be worse just it's like we stopped the immediate
threat but things are only going to get worse
damage is done now we gotta reset again like
it it felt like kind of a worthy way to end such
a a lengthy Arc of movies but that you know will
never stop being made yeah so like yeah to do
that just brilliant white you know white light
absorbing everything was really nice and I did
like that it felt like well we tried these heroes
are heroes but there was no coming back but they
still won yeah that's what I'm saying like it was
it was both things yeah it's it's a fun Nuance of
an ending because yeah it's like we won the battle
but we didn't win the overall war and that's what
we need to now you know go back and literally
resetting a universe because of the like Horrors
yeah and two I feel like it doesn't to me it
doesn't like negate or cheapen anything that came
before to have the reset happen because it's like
we wouldn't have been able to do that if we lost
we would have lost everything things would have
only gotten you know worse person words and words
Dark Side would have conquered all yeah and now at
least we have Barry back so that we can in order
to reset yeah and no one else could have done it
I also love that Constantine and Flash basically
became the leads that's the thing too is is in a
movie like this I I was pleasantly surprised by
it I like that in a lot of I think Constantine
appearances he does sort of like rise to being
something of a crucial player or a semi-leader
and an also audience Cipher all in one yeah and
in a movie like this you know you expect like oh
Batman Superman are probably going to be the most
prominent and it's like John Constantine it's it's
like an ensemble piece certainly and it's not just
focused on him it's not like the Constantine movie
but at the same time he does kind of yeah like
even over Harley Quinn even over Batman like
even over yeah and I really like that when it was
on The Suicide Squad it let it be a Suicide Squad
movie yeah like I always talk about how hard
it is to like an artist Jam page where it's
like Jim Lee drawing and capullo drawing and top
McFarland and like they managed to make this all
feel authentic to each other's teams in one big
long title movie yeah I was so impressed man this
was really spectacular and like I I've talked
a lot about like my you know version of these
characters I've came to love this take on them
enough that I was so invested in them at this
this ending yeah well to get a few I know we've
talked a lot about romance and passion and this
wasn't like super focused on those but we did
get a couple of loving wrap-ups with people at
the end Starfire Nightwing her broken and like a
fury in him like insane yeah that was brutal but
but reunited and the last thing Lois and Clark
got to have their moment together like I love
you there were so many of those Great Moments yeah
and those I thought you know those made it sort of
feel like even though again it's not been like
the main flavor of this whole journey it made
it feel like yeah that stuff was always there it's
always been growing and this was a nice way to put
a human a personal an emotional stamp as well
as the cool action and the Sci-Fi and all that
stuff and yeah just like putting the stamp on the
story itself uh yeah I was impressed yeah and the
array of magic and powers and the whole thing
was zatana too it was really cool tying it all
back into magic like because that's the thing
that can defeat Superman tying the Kryptonite
that Lex would have there was really good long
game villainy and and solves yeah and and two
having it be like okay Lex is the one feeding them
info Batman really has been corrupted yeah it's a
deeper kind of saving in order and then it was
the other obvious but it was just tricky enough
that I didn't think of it yeah yeah yeah and two
I I really thought the beat of Constantine being
like why did I run and and blaming myself I love
that being yeah and drinking himself to death out
of guilt yeah like feeling so guilty and ashamed
of that decision that ultimately actually wasn't
a decision I thought was so lovely and to it
and Batman it makes Batman even cooler I love
how like good writing makes Batman the coolest
yeah he was like you know what might happen
um spell on unconstantine yeah and I
love the constant immediately was like
he didn't blame her he blamed Batman immediately
that's exactly I love that yeah and that also
made it like I was sad to not have Zatanna because
like in her brief appearances I really liked her
presence and her rapport with Constantine all
that stuff but like I thought that made really
nice bookends for this and that that satisfied my
heart and the romance was lovely and then Heaven
scene was great and and Trigon had fun etragon and
he went out on a rhyme and not only on a rhyme but
on the rhyme about him having fun having fun this
one thing took out an entire third of the problem
I love this swampy got to be like awesome this
really did a great job giving a lot of people
their due yeah totally I was wondering how he came
back but I'm not thinking too too hard about that
because I think the last time we saw him he was
like they did like wither him away oh yeah but
uh I'm sure that's okay the green brought him
back yeah he just had a Little Seedling yeah I
know James Gunn loves these movies so I'm really
excited to see if he can I mean imagine if he can
build the like something like that that would be
amazing like that would make Avengers La Quint so
is yeah yeah because this does feel interconnected
but in ways you know it's got an interesting blend
of ways where it's obvious how they're connected
and in ways in which it's not obvious until much
later all those different tones it like feels
like Infinity war and end game and like the big
team up so this was and but this is 90 minutes
I want to see 40 movies lead to something like
this I know I want the next 10 years of my life
to lead to something this crazy absolutely oh
well I think that is going to do it uh this
was an absolute spectacular uh we're gonna do
something to rank the DC AMU we're not sure the
format yet but uh just this Canon we're gonna do
a ranking of and then when we get to the the big
DC Pie in the Sky what's crazy is while we keep
watching those more will come out but at some
point we'll go like we've seen 50 or something
but like we're gonna watch like a swath of those
but we're gonna rank the DC AMU because I love me
some lists uh we'll we'll keep you guys posted
so leave a comment let us know your ranking and
how you think we should rank them but before we
get out of here let's give some Patron love too
Chase Gardner you know why because Flash
because Flash has Chase Swamp Thing and
Swamp Thing that's actually perfect perfect two
players integral pieces of this puzzle one is in
the green and one's gotta move fast Chase Gardner
love that good call that's you buddy you are the
person we would call upon the crisis of infinite
Earths of time of uh what other crises uh I mean
you hit the big ones yeah I mean infinite crises
crisis has never heard said the two that I think
of there's just general crises to start out the
craze we need you for all of them all any and all
crisis we're turning to you buddy because you're
steady frankly you're the strength that can take
out a third of the problem and the one that has
to take out the big problem at the end because
that's how good you are so MVP situation Mr Chase
Gardner much appreciated the hero so stay pledged
buddy that keep your spot at the top of of you
know your league yeah at the top of the league
you know we we all answer to you you know you're
like Our Benevolent dark side as well there you go
high price tied into the whole kitten caboodle my
friend but we love you we appreciate your support
every month and we will catch you next time Chase
Gardner is all right that's gonna do what you
lovelies we are done with the DC AMU we will be
back for something else TBD leave a comment below
hit that like share this video all the things
much love reject Nation we'll see you soon